suffering is almost a catalyst right to
push us on the path and what I see
happen on a collective level more more
people are suffering because there's
something bigger happened let's start
from the spiritual perspective there's a
divine force the super mental
consciousness if she open as she opened
a moment ago Yoga would say is trying to
anchor itself during this time of
transition right but it is bringing up
everything that is not a line of truth
right so it is not this like all of a
sudden everything will be in paradise
but it brings up everything we have not
looked at we have no we have avoided and
a lot of a lot of people that is very
intense yeah are they going through a
lot of tribulations you know and then a
person lives emotionally but it needs
the vessel needs to clear itself right
within so we can truly anchor the divine
yes and that's just a very intense
process right now and and I see what's
happening in the world it's it's it's
over and over the same people get
distracted by the shadows on the wall
they're influenced by forces or cold
forces they have no awareness of there
they fall into this divide-and-conquer
trap